dark mouse is a top-down action RPG by
indie developer Daniel Wright it takes a
lot of direct inspiration from Dark
Souls but it also builds upon the genre
in interesting ways and right now you
might be put off by that simple
aesthetic and so was I at first but
after 16 hours with this game I'm really
glad I stuck with it because dark mouse
does a lot with very little take that
visual aesthetic for example right the
color scheme is mainly made up of tan
black and Gray's which really doesn't
allow for a lot of detail to be
expressed but dark mouse decides to use
this to its advantage dark and light
become a crucial theme and the way that
line of sight is illuminated around
corners adds a haunting limbo esque
flavor to the game and this is a
developer who understands that gameplay
has to come first so the lighting and
the illumination of darkness has
gameplay implications occasionally
allowing you a sliver of vision into an
adjacent room or revealing enemies that
are lying in ambush meaning that you
have to be ready to fight at a moment's
notice
speaking of which let's fight against
this red eye knight who is revealed to
be resting around the corner in a cave
here he's one of your Mouse's
doppelgangers found throughout the world
and he mimics the weaponry and the
gameplay style that you've built up
throughout the game we both fight with a
spiked shield a curved fire imbued sword
and pyromancy spells and he quickly
overpowers me the difficulty is no joke
it's easily the most challenging game
that I've played all year the way you
control difficulty is through the ghosts
that rise alongside you at the bonfire
when you die these shades will follow
the path you last took when you died
fighting everything in their way and
disappearing when they die or when they
reach the point where you last died
meaning that every time you encounter
something in dark Mouse you have to do
it alone
the first time
but then when you die to it you get
these companions who fight alongside you
it's dark mouse's major contribution to
the souls genre and I was surprised that
I liked it as much as I did
fighting with your ghosts felt like
fighting with summoned help in Dark
Souls and you can even turn it off if
it's making things too easy but the
thing is it doesn't exactly make things
easy sometimes this ghost mechanic
simply puts you on even footing with the
really really difficult parts of the
game together me and my ghosts corner
the red-eye night we're whittling away
at his health until I am the only one
who remains a Dodger every attack I set
up for the final blow and I die yeah
it's tough honestly I think some parts
of the difficulty even need to be toned
down it's that tough for example towards
the end of the game there's this
gauntlet where you fight a multitude of
enemy mice these were so difficult that
I absolutely needed my shades to fight
alongside me which was a good example of
when the game felt almost too hard
because I was actually dying so I could
get shades to help me and this felt
mandatory needing to die to get help is
a pretty shitty situation but that said
I did go most of the game without
feeling this way so the most part the
ghost mechanic works pretty well but
let's take a step back and getting too
far ahead
you have your standard Souls control
scheme you have your light attacks your
heavy attacks your block and your dodge
shield in your left hand sword pyromancy
or bow in your right and access to an
inventory where you heal upgrade weapons
and equipment are is in the top-left
but the stamina bar is actually the
light bar in the center of the screen
which I like it highlights just how
important stamina management is in this
game the soul style combat is translated
really well to top-down rewarding
well-timed blocks and parries and
punishing overly aggressive reckless
play one of the coolest additions is the
abilities screen where you can regularly
in
best talent points that unlock new moves
and it's clever because if you had all
of these unlocked moves from the very
start then it would be way too
complicated and confusing as it stands
though you can use this ability screen
to unlock abilities related to the
situation you're in so if you're getting
shot at with arrows you can deflect
those arrows with the appropriate
ability if you're fighting against these
little spiders that keep their distance
and only attack you when your back is
turned then you can get the dash attack
and run at them and kill them
before they can back away with the
ability system you actively feel your
character getting more powerful and I
like it as you progress through the game
you find marrow which is used to invest
in your stats at the bonfire health
stamina weight capacity resilience to
stun locking and dexterity to increase
your attack speed these are all stats
that you can invest in but an odd choice
is the ability to level up your
proficiency with certain weapon classes
here which I suppose is an easier to
understand version of the strength and
dexterity system of Dark Souls but the
drawback here is that it has the
unwanted side effect of forcing a player
to choose one class of weapon that
they'll have to stick with so this
coupled with the lack of variety of
weapons in the early game will likely
frustrate a lot of players as they
invest in the wrong weapons or they'll
end up wishing that they could switch
those stats they invested in later on if
you do want to play this game I've left
a link in the description to a short
written guide to the weapons and
mechanics which I recommend you check
out if you're having trouble or you
don't want to go in totally blind
it stops you making those investment
mistakes combat like Souls largely
revolves around learning enemy patterns
and
predicting their attacks most enemies
have these patterns of behavior which
means that once you figure them out
they're much easier to take out some of
the most fun I had is in these rooms
full of ranged enemies we're taking out
the enemies in the right order almost
felt like a sort of puzzle not to
mention all the traps in some levels
this one castle is like sense fortress
on steroids so dark mouse felt a lot
like hotline Miami if you've played that
game where you find yourself mapping out
the best way to deal with certain rooms
full of enemies and traps and then you
would execute that strategy you would do
it over and over tweaking it slightly
each time until you found the perfect
way to make your way through a room I'd
sort of lost that feeling in souls to be
honest but I enjoyed it in dark mouse
and it's actually very very difficult to
run past everything and just rest at the
next checkpoint which is a common
problem in souls games most enemies in
dark Mouse can match or even exceed the
speed that you run which really really
makes it difficult to run past stuff not
to mention they follow you a ridiculous
distance and you can't rest it bonfires
until you've killed them all so this
results in you often being really low on
health and creeping forward slowly just
hoping to see a bonfire enter the edge
of your screen bonfires are placed
really close together in this game but I
assume that's partly to do with the
difficulty and also because your ability
to heal in dark mouse is quite limited
random enemies drop morsels which act as
your healing and you'll have a good
store of them in the early game but by
the late game a morsel is like finding a
divine blessing in Dark Souls you only
want to use them when you really really
need to and in the version I played you
couldn't even heal in combat but the
developers always posting on the stained
page and he says that now there's a
designated button for healing which is
great but because morsels drops so
infrequently your health is a premium
that you want to preserve at all
and because health is so important this
inevitably leads to you letting your
ghosts do as much of the fighting as
possible when you get to a really tough
part and generally this was only a
problem in the late game where I started
to have a really hard time and I started
to rely on my ghost so a lot more but
thing is you don't want to ever really
be relying on your ghosts to do all the
fighting for you that feels really bad
so in the future I'd kind of like to see
more plentiful healing along with
slightly weaker ghosts so it just
increases that level of player agency
that you have moving on you definitely
don't feel alone in dark mouse even
though it's single player
there are to escort quests I'm aware of
there's one s called quest I'm really a
big fan of the character has her traits
reinforced by her reactions to enemies
and she has this story that really
drives the narrative of the game and you
start to care about this character more
because she's helping you and characters
that help you in terms of game player
characters you'll end up empathizing
more with I think that makes sense right
the other escort had a tendency to get
lost behind me and kept dying to traps
plus he required me to invest a morsel a
bit of my healing in him to keep him
going so I was getting punished pretty
hard for this guy's bad reaction to all
the traps so I guess you could argue
that this was in keeping with his
character since he was meant to be a
weak warrior that you're dragging along
with you but I ended up getting pretty
frustrated with him no matter how in
keeping with his character that is but
yeah you never feel alone
ghosts fill the rooms that you're having
trouble with and at random intervals
this happens
a powerful hunter will appear rush you
down and kill you then feed on your
marrow if you die to him your maximum
health is halved and it will slowly come
back over time now in a game this hard
this is actually terrifying from
software have been trying to figure out
how to make invaders scary for a while
now in Dark Souls 2 for example they had
them invade at random intervals but dark
mouse actually gets it right by making
invaders have the opportunity to reduce
your health by half when they find you
and successfully hunt you down you
actually are pretty scared of having
half your health reduced so I do find it
pretty funny that this indie game got
that right
they make hunters and invaders pretty
scary but back to what I said at the
start this game does a lot with a little
the music is really on point and a lot
of the ambient music was even great
enough for me to put in this video for
example the boss tracks though that's
the thing I love the most
a lot of the boss music actually matches
the movement of the boss which makes the
tracks really memorable a one thing I
also loved was that the boss music
persists after you die to the boss and I
think this says that the game developer
really knows that players will throw
themselves at a boss over and over again
it's great the thumping beat of the
music keeps you hyped and it continually
reminds you of what your goal is and
which boss you're facing and it's much
more engaging I liked it it's all about
those little things dark mouse even
users can resume Stu great effect
narrowing your camera in tight sections
and expanding it when you're exploring a
vast plane exploration is a big heart of
darkness to you hug the walls and
eventually you'll find little optional
paths that hide treasures like marrow
and weapons and amulets also you have a
torch which restricts your ability to
explore new areas if it runs out however
my never really ran out unless I was
writing this script and I'd pause
the game so a lot of the time exploring
felt like an early zelda game in the
sense that you're constantly pulling out
your map and figuring out where you are
and which rooms you haven't explored yet
I loved that but I really wish my map
would stop deleting the old areas that I
had already explored it made exploring
one Castle a huge pain in the ass
because rooms I had already explored
would go dark on my map in closing I do
think that dark mouse is a really great
achievement as an indie game it brings
out some of the best elements that Dark
Souls pioneered and it even pioneers
some new mechanics of its own as time
goes on I realized that's what's going
to make a Souls like game stand out from
the rest it's coming up with a new
mechanic like the ghost system and
inserting it and seeing how it really
changes the souls mechanics and seeing
how that souls experience can be
emphasized and brought down different
ways and I think that dark mouse nails
it it still needs polish in some areas
and you'll get frustrated at some points
when you play it but it's easily worth
the $10 price and it's easily worth
sticking it through and getting through
the frustrating bits because there are a
lot of great moments in this game plus
this is actually the first souls like
game I've covered that's actually
available for purchase so go get it if
you're interested and bear in mind that
if I was more critical in this video
it's because the game is out and your
money is on the line and this is more of
a review than a preview so if you're
currently craving Dark Souls 3 I reckon
this is the best thing to tide you over
until then and I also did a little
patreon playthrough for this game so if
that sort of thing interests you you can
become a $5 patron and see that stuff in
the future so yeah regardless thank you
for watching and I'll see you in the
next one okay